[Music]
where'd you watch the superbowl reg
right here in good old Malibu really
party good old Malibu knows no party
those days are over with the kids but
you know I tried to get mini me you know
hooked on the Super Bowl which was
awesome because listening to the call
every time Brady you know through one of
those you know unbelievable passes and
catches you just cuss ain't catched yes
he had no rooting interest either did I
but it was just cool to see him react to
you know situation I mean it literally
you you were watching greatness I mean
isn't this how we want a super bowl to
go down you want the two best teams and
you want them to put on an unbelievable
show which it was and you want people to
be at their best or perform at their
best especially under a little bit of
distress and we saw that with Tom Brady
and look when they were down 28 to three
it's funny because you know I like again
I had no rooting interest in either team
but people seem to think hitting me on
Twitter showing the meme of you know the
choking meme of me with my hands around
but they would put Brady's face over my
face saying Brady's choking Brady showed
us out so then when the comeback happen
to win because I mean people are like it
was look Tom Brady I fought it cuz you
tonight look I don't hold I told you I
fought it with the LeBron James Larry
Bird I had to put LeBron on my all-time
top five yeah and I'm fighting it
because you and I both grew up with
super Joe we grew up with super Joe
right super Joe Montana we have our
quarterback yeah but to let it go I
gotta let it go right Brady is better
than Joe Montana he's going to be
recognized as the greatest quarterback
of all time now here was a discussion I
had at the super bowl and some of the
guys who play still play had a problem
with this I said can Brady be considered
just player not just quarterback the
greatest NFL player of all time I know
no I that would probably go to maybe
like a Walter Payton a Jerry Rice hey
Jim Brown more of the skills type of
don't get me wrong but Brady great arm a
great vision as a quarterback but he's
not a great mobile quarterback I would
say I would go as far to say Aaron
Rodgers is probably a better athletic
quarterback and Tom Brady's that fair oh
yeah yeah but you had does this come
down to athleticism your greatness is
your athleticism I would say so yes yes
not player everybody definitely he is
the greatest quarterback of all time
have you ever hung with Tom Brady I have
not never many i met him in passing but
I've never hung with him hung you're
talking about like we're in the booth
together it was in the club and we
exchanged pleasantries but I didn't hang
with him he had all the supermodels over
there and I had the cast off wait what
what year is this what I just kidding
what year is it ok this is a long time
ago i'm talking 15 years this is before
Tom Brady Tom Brady you know before he
became a brand before he was t be 12 he
was just I was doing great maybe after
his first win but he still wasn't Tom
Brady people were still he wasn't you
know when you say Tom Brady you're
supposed to go afterwards you know now
he wasn't he wasn't that Tom Brady he's
Reggie Miller joining us the Hall of
Famer Dan Patrick show and you lost in
NBA Finals and you didn't lose in
crushing fashion like the Falcons did
but you're still lost i don't know if
you're reminded that often about it but
the falcons losing the way they lost how
long does it stay with them you and I'm
sorry to say this to you Falcons fans
you will remember this crushing defeat
for ever because I replay
one through six on a daily basis now it
doesn't run continuous but I remember
the losses more so in that six-game
series with the Lakers more so than I do
the wins because in the losses what if I
could have gotten that extra rebound
that Luther ball what if I were to close
out the Kobe a little bit harder what if
we could have fouled Shaq 20 more times
and fit into the line 80 times as
opposed to 60 you replay the losses a
lot more and to be up 28 3 and all
things clicking and then too I mean
really it came down to a sack and a
penalty that took you out of field goal
range that's what it basically came down
to those two mistakes you kick a field
goal we're sitting here talking about
Matty ice right so those two mistakes
they are going to replay look sure there
was a full game but to me those two
plays really turned things around and
Brady became Brady but it's the losses
that I always remember and very much the
same way if you're a seattle seahawks
man you will replay that what first and
goal over and over again if you're Pete
Carroll again oh who else Tom Brady in
New England and even though you have a
super bowl any mail you he'll ask you
about it yeah wouldn't we be talking
about Seattle a whole lot different I'm
back to back n Bowl champion Jay would
be like up there with you know San
Francisco and Pittsburgh I mean we would
look at Seattle a whole lot different
it's great if they want to Chester don't
get me wrong but to be back to back
Russell limit or Russell Wilson to be
back to back super bowl champions and
yeah it's the crushing defeats that is
this is a crushing defeat for Atlanta
all right help me out with what's going
on with the Cavaliers hear that there's
a report in The Daily News Frank Isola
who covers the Knicks who said that you
know they're interested in Carmelo going
there and LeBron would give up Kevin
Love now you got the Cavs coming up
thursday night any truth to this any
validity to this
well I'm sure where there's smoke
there's fires but at good we've heard
this before though I mean this is not
nothing new that Carmelo and LeBron
obviously does friends but haven't we
heard this before I mean this isn't the
first just because Frank said it nobody
feels like a couple weeks ago but
there's the you know quote or somebody
attaching a quote to LeBron saying that
yes go ahead you know I'll sign off and
giving up Kevin Love for karma now that
that I'm not quite sure there's a lot of
validity to that why would they do that
would you do that it would not give we
talked about this last week absolutely
not I mean ever loved is four years
younger than Carmelo Anthony and if last
night's game was any indication that's
what Kevin Love is capable of doing on a
nightly basis but remember he is the
third option on that team the third
option behind LeBron and Kyrie and he
put up numbers like that so if people
expect those numbers all the time
Carmelo is not going to come in and put
up numbers like that he would be the
third option on the Cavs team but no I
absolutely would not do that deal and if
the Cavs do that I have some land to
sell them as well but they needed
claiming they LeBron says he wants a
playmaker in the am can add some depth
Carmelo doesn't give you that that's
what I don't I don't understand I will
tell you the playmaker they need to go
out and get LeBron James 17 assists last
night there's your play maker right
there did you think I'll Kyrie Irving
into that game when LeBron had fouled
out yeah that's their team that's why I
if I'm LeBron James I'm not fearing
Golden State I'm not fear in San Antonio
or Boston or Toronto or Washington I got
these dogs with me why do I need to go
out and worried about what someone else
is doing in their house worried about my
house my house is pretty good because I
got my third ring with these guys that's
what I don't understand about this Ridge
if I'm LeBron I don't want to show
weakness and you're showing weakness by
admitting that your team is not only you
could say hey this is who we have this
is
this is my knees are my team this my
team these my boys my dog yeah I'm
rolling with these dudes these dudes
help me get a third they brought a
championship for the land something that
has not happened in over 50 years I'm
rolling with these guys now behind
closed doors can you go to general
manager am you sure yes but don't make
it pop we go say hey you know we're top
heavy and we need this no I'm the
baddest dude I've been the baddest dude
in his League for the last 10 to 14
years the face of the league not cool
man I don't want to hear that from you I
just got it we are back we are the
defending champ we are the dispatcher
that's the point they you know last I
look we won they they were desperate
they had to get seven derail you know
what I say I don't care about Kevin
Durant I did him in the final that's
what I'm saying this is the mentality
this is how I would be talking about I
know that I know that come in a ranch
avail so dude I did you in the finals
were you talking about so what do you
want to zoom same thing is going to
happen that's how I would be talking now
I have no rings but position that's how
I would be honest have fun in Oklahoma
City it'll be the Thunder and the Cavs
that's thursday night 8 Eastern on TNT
is Reggie Aloysius Miller safe travels
reg great to talk to you bum Theodore
you and the den net truly you take these
show to a different level my friend
thanks reg and I'm not asking for any
backup here I'm not asking that
management give me some other people
here you're my you're my gosh you're my
boys right here that's all I need going
into battle signal counter Kevin Love
type yes that's what I need Pass me the
ball the Dan Patrick show weekday
morning on audience
[Music]